I just wanted to ask a question cuz um
earlier this year I lost my little
sister. She passed away.
>> Uh she was 28.
>> She rest in peace. Well, I don't know
the circumstances and Okay. But what you
asking me exactly?
>> Uh I just wanted to ask cuz at at the
time like when it was her last day, we
were all there as a family and our
pastors were there and um like we were
all praying and believing in like
>> Yeah. She had a it was like an unknown
infection and there was like nothing I
could do. Um but yeah, I was just
wondering cuz we're all like praying and
for healing and like could there be any
way that it could be like maybe our
prayers weren't good enough or our faith
wasn't like strong enough or anything
like that?
>> You think that
she had to be healed and she wasn't
healed because your faith was weak?
Where'd you get this theology from?
No, I don't know. It's just what some
people say
>> that. Oh, you mean maybe our faith was
weak and we couldn't save her. So God is
that cruel and heartless that her
helling was depend on your prayers and
cuz you failed them. Okay, I'm going to
take your sister away. Come on, man.
What kind of Even the question is
offending me.
>> Yeah.
>> What kind of God do you serve that you
would believe? Oh, see, God is so cruel
that if we didn't pray hard enough in
faith, then he's going to take my sister
away. But if we had true faith, she'd be
healed. Darn it, she died. That means
our prayers were not good enough. And
but God is saying, "So sad, too bad."
Really?
>> To say that, "Oh, because we didn't have
enough faith or we didn't pray hard
enough and therefore we failed her and
she died." Was she a believer?
>> Yeah. Yeah. She loved she loved the
Lord, loved Jesus.
>> Where's she now?
>> Uh she's in the best place possible.
>> So then how did God fail you when now
she's deathless, painfree, cancer free,
and she can never be sick anymore?
>> Do you have an eternal perspective or
you think only only this life matters?
So even if he healed her, she's going to
still die anyway, right?
>> Yeah. True.
>> But now is she deathless?
>> Yep.
>> Is she
painless?
Yep.
>> Is she now free from any misery and
sadness and depression?
>> Yeah.
>> Is she?
>> Is she or isn't she?
>> She is.
>> So then you got bad theology and you got
a wrong perspective.
>> Yeah. I I think like Yeah. I think
that's not really what I believe, but
it's just just a question like in the
back of my mind like is it my fault or
so? God needed you to have enough faith
to spare your daughter uh your sister so
that because you didn't have enough
faith now God punishes you by taking
your sister away. Come on, man.
>> Wake up. This is not the God revealed in
Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah. So when Steven got martyed, the
church failed him. Huh?
>> No.
>> No. They failed him because they prayed
hard enough. Then he wouldn't have died.
What are you talking about?
>> Jesus himself, what was in his 30s when
he died? Late 30s.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, so God failed Jesus.
>> No.
>> When the Bible is full of examples of
people dying.
Some die young, some die old.
David was 70 when he died. Solomon was
60.
Okay. So that means
>> brother,
>> you got to not buy into this garbage.
They're lying to you and deceiving you
into telling you that if you have faith,
you'll never get sick. So then what do
you do with all the people who did get
sick and who did die of illness because
not everyone was healed?
>> Yeah.
Um
I don't know. I guess there was nothing
that we could really do.
>> How did you fail her? In fact, doesn't
Paul say to depart to be with Christ is
far better than remaining with you?
>> Yeah.
>> No, but according to you is better if
she stayed with you
because this is the gloom you're having.
Philippians 1:21 23. For to me to live
is Christ and to die is gain. But if I
am to live on in the flesh, this will
mean fruitful labor for I'm going to
keep doing ministry and I do not know
what I will choose. But I'm hardressed
between the two, having desired to
depart and be with Christ, for that is
far better. Which is far better?
>> To die.
>> So why you guys gloom gloom all of the
fact? Oh, we failed her. So you're
basically saying Paul is a liar because
it was better for her to stay in the
flesh.
>> Your theology that you're being taught
is bad theology. It's garbage,
>> right?
>> Yep.
>> Stop believing this garbage theology
that's not biblical,
>> you with me there?
>> Yeah.
>> Here, let me show. So, uh, these people
that teach such poisonous demonic
doctrines
>> kills me.
>> Okay. Second Timothy 4:20. Arasus
remained at Corinth, but Trophimus I
left sick at Malitos. So could Trophyus
travel with Paul?
>> Uh, no.
>> Why?
Why couldn't he go with him?
>> Because he was sick.
>> Oh, but I guess Paul didn't have enough
faith, huh? Because if he had faith, he
wouldn't be sick. He'd be healed.
>> Yeah. I guess so.
Get rid of this bad garbage theology.
Your sister is alive, man.
>> Yeah.
>> And she's resting. In fact, the Bible
says in the presence of God are eternal
pleasures
>> in his presence. And I'm going to show
you right here.
All right.
So, I don't know, man. I don't know why
you let these these
false teachers, these sons of Satan,
make you more depressed. Oh, I failed my
sister. Hold on. I thought I believe in
Jesus. Yeah.
>> And if Jesus is alive, she's alive.
Yeah. And she's in a glorified state.
She can't sin. Yeah. And she has a white
robe resting. Yeah. What the hell am I
miserable about? I don't know.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Here, let me show you.
Okay. I don't get it. these people who
deceive you guys. Paul said to leave the
body, to depart from money, and to be
with the Lord is better.
>> Is that what I just read to you?
Philippians 121:23.
>> Do I need to reread it or you forgot it?
>> No, that's all good. I got it.
>> You got it. Okay. So, you believe it?
>> Yep.
>> You sure?
>> Yeah.
>> Why are you so sad then?
Um,
>> how'd you fail her? Psalm 16:10-11. For
you not si forsake my soul to show.
You'll not give your holy one over to
see corruption. You'll make known to me
the path of life. In your presence is
fullness of joy. In your right hand
there are pleasures forever.
So she had God's right hand, Jesus's
right hand.
>> Yep.
>> Then do you believe she's now
experiencing infinite joy and love and
pleasures?
Yeah.
>> So, how did you fail her?
>> Psalm 17:15, "As for me, I shall behold
your face in righteousness. I'll be
satisfied with your likeness when I
awake." When her soul left her body, she
awakened to the spirit realm.
>> So, she now seeing his face?
>> Yep.
>> Would you rather have her see God's face
or your face? Uh,
>> God's face. So, how did you fail her?
>> I don't know.
>> Hebrews 12:22- 24.
>> Listen to this. Hebrews 12:22- 24. But
you have come to Mount Zion, to the city
of the living God, the heavenly
Jerusalem, and to my angels, to the
festival gathering and assembly of the
firstborn, enrolled in heaven, and to
God the judge of all, and to the spirits
of the righteous men made perfect.
Righteous made perfect. Notice this is
heaven, right? Heavenly Jerusalem.
>> Yep.
>> See, it's in heaven, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Jerusalem heaven. Who lives in that
heaven? Angels, right?
>> Yep.
>> Also, believers who are gathered there
and assembling there, they're there,
right?
>> God is there, right?
>> Yep.
>> Now, notice what's there. The spirits of
the righteous made perfect. the spirits
of perfect believers. But where are
their bodies?
>> On earth.
>> They're where?
>> They're on earth.
>> Yeah. That's why they're there in
spirits, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Is your sister one of them?
>> Yep.
>> But now that means she's perfect.
>> She's seeing God the Father.
>> She's now with angels.
>> And she's seeing Jesus Christ cuz he's
there, too.
Why are you then
miserable that you thought you fail her?
You're saying then it was better for her
to stay with you than with Jesus.
>> Uh I guess it's just like a
fleshly desire to want to be like want
her to stay here.
>> Yes. We all want our loved ones stay
here, but eventually you got to die,
right? Until Christ comes.
>> Yeah. And when you see Jesus, do you
want to come back to earth?
>> Uh, no way.
>> So your sister is better than you cuz
you can sin,
>> you can stumble, you can still feel pain
and misery, depression. She can't feel
any of that and can't do any of that
anymore.
>> And she's now seeing God the Father's
glory and the physical face of Jesus.
And she's seeing angels.
>> And you're saying you failed her.
How did you fail her?
>> Even for those of you saying she needs
your prayers, you still don't get it.
Even for those of you in purgatory,
Catholics, wake up. Purgatory means
she's guaranteed heaven. Take it easy,
man. And that's a process of
purification that's done out of love.
Pure love. Take it easy, Catholics. Take
it easy, man.
I hope that you're not counseling me
when I'm dying because you would suck.
Anyway, you with me there?
>> Yep.